من قام بتحضر المنتخب المغربي هو والد
الركراكي
ووليدتهما اللعابه المنتخب الوطني واستطاع
كيفما قلته الاستاذ محمد فانه في ظرف وجيز
استطاع انه يكون توليفه مهمه رائعه جدا
انسجن باهر
يعني تواصل خارق للعاده الحمد لله والشكر
لله كما قال سيدنا الحسن الثاني الله
يرحمه برحمته الله قال لا تستغفر
نفسك بس تخسرش نفسك
على راس الكاتبه الوطنيه على راس المنتخب
الوطني
والجميع الملكيه المغربيه لكره القدم
ما قلتي شهرين
واستطاع انه يبصم على بصمه همم كبيره جدا
انا همم امام الكره العالميه اليوم وليد
الركراكي له شان في الكره العالميه اصبح
عنده شان كبير واللي عضا اصبح عالمين رغم
انهم تلعبوا في الفرق عالميه ولا يهبونا
اي فريق فهمتي حق الانجازات
طموح كبير باش نتخطى وتدور النصف النهائي
ونلعبوا عليه كاس العالم ان شاء الله